the world cup kicks off with hosts  Brazil facing croatia in the opening  game on june the 1230 two nations will  battle it out for the biggest prize in  football as we look at the top half of  the draw Brazil are under pressure on  home soil Group B features the holders  Spain against strong opposition in Chile  and the Netherlands c is for columbia  and the Ivory Coast and who could call  Group D with heavyweights England Italy  and Europe wide as we look at the bottom  half of the draw France will hope to top  group e and banish memories of 2010's  failure Leo Messi's Argentina are one of  the favorites to lift the trophy things  look straight forward for them in Group  F G is for Germany and for Ghana  alongside Portugal and the USA in one of  the tougher groups and Group H features  Belgium and its star-studded squad all  routes to the final on July the 13th